you
[Music]
surprise to prize second game of Thrones
teaser in as many days so it seems like
we're building up to something really
big let's break this down
getting the mad queen ready for her
scene this is so great
it almost seems like they're ramping up
to something even bigger like
behind-the-scenes featurette or just
something that's a little more full in
these really quick teasers but they
stuck this one at the end of big little
lives which has had its finale so it's
almost like they're attaching Game of
Thrones stuff to the end of ongoing HBO
series like whenever the finales
happened for other series that are
airing but the thing is is the next big
thing that's ending for them is girls
season six and that's not till the end
of April so that's a ways off
so because South by Southwest is
literally happening in the next couple
of days they might be dropping something
even bigger that's been the theory for a
while so we got to talk about Cersei
you're on and what's happening in King's
Landing during season seven so there is
a new round of the game of Thrones
giveaway I'm giving away the enhanced
editions of the books all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video so the point at
which we left Cersei is that she was
being crowned Queen amongst this crowd
of really frightened looking people
nobody looked happy when they were
standing there like oh my god our worst
nightmare
just came true the queen that we just
mocked and paraded naked through the
streets is now in charge of everyone and
because her children are dead she is
completely unburdened of any morality
that she had before if there was
anything good in her before it was her
children now that that is gone you can
only imagine how terrible she's going to
be she is going to put your on Greyjoy
to shame when it comes to villains
during season seven maybe not book your
on if you're not familiar with book
euron greyjoy
there's so many more terrible things
that they allude to what he's done over
the years he sexually abused his younger
brothers remember he's the brother of
Balon Greyjoy Victarion
in the damp hair in the way George R
Martin has presented him is that he's
going to be much more terrible in the
future so no idea how the TV show is
going to address that but the damn pair
has this nightmarish vision of Euron as
these lashed to the prow of your on ship
where he sees you're on on the Iron
Throne sitting next to someone with fair
hair wearing Valyrian armor so it's
almost like the damn pair is having a
vision of your
potentially becoming king of westeros so
it seems like it's going to be really
terrible but TV show you're on isn't
quite as big of a character quite as big
of a villain barring White Walkers in
the night king south of the wall it
sounds like they're presenting Cersei as
the final boss of season seven but the
problem is is that because the Tyrells
controls a grain supply in Westeros or
at least most of the grain and they've
aligned with the Targaryen restoration
Cersei is going to run out of food very
soon remember that story that Stannis
told about how the Onion Knight saved
him during Robert's rebellion he was
holed up in storms and they were running
out of supplies they had to hold out for
more than six months to a year they had
eaten the horses they had eaten all the
leather they were eating anything that
was in Iraq
so Davos basically like smuggles in
onions and that's how he became The
Onion Knight because he brought them
food even though was onions it was still
some form of sustenance that helped them
survive to the end of Robert's rebellion
so I don't think it's going to get quite
that desperate for Cersei I don't think
the season is going to take place over a
six month period so they do have
supplies in King's Landing that will
probably last but the thing is is King's
Landing is a really big place and
they're going to run out of food really
fast no matter what and there's the
problem of Daenerys as fleet and that's
really where you get into Euron's true
value at sea that's really where his
power is so it seems like rapid transit
system style compression of time Euron
has rebuilt himself a fleet and will
just harass Daenerys fleet as much as
possible so there is this big Daenerys
Cersei battle that they're hyping up but
you also have this Greyjoy family civil
war that's going on - that was the whole
reason for them aligning with Daenerys
you help us get rid of our uncle we'll
help you take Westeros so if you feel
like they brushed over you're on in
season six it sounds like he's going to
be much more critical to Circe's
campaign in season seven and hopefully
they'll let him have some fun because
he's really great as a villain I feel
like that's where his real strength in
the narrative is is being this huge
antagonist even if he's going to be a
much bigger antagonist and wins the
winter the book that he is on the TV
show but can you just imagine the terms
he's going to extract from Cersei in
exchange for his help except I'm the one
who's going to build
the IFV because I'm the one who knows
how to use it
I've been all over the world I've seen
more of it than all of you combined
and across the sea there is a person who
hates the great lords of westeros just
as much as we do someone with a large
army three large dragons and no husband
I'm going to build that fleet and I'm
going to get a van ride over and give it
to Daenerys Targaryen along with my big
[ __ ] he was all about perving after
Daenerys so now it sounds like he's
going to be harassing Cersei in that
same way to just being the worst human
imaginable in the best possible way
because what does Cersei have to offer
there is no king so she can offer her
hand in marriage but her big thing is
that she doesn't want to have anything
to do with getting married like they've
tried to force her to marry Loras and
she wasn't having it she's like I'm not
getting married again I didn't want to
get married to Robert in the first place
I'm done being forced to do things that
I don't want to do but now it sounds
like the big twist is that she's going
to be forced into an alliance with Joran
so let me know what you guys think is
going to happen she's forced to team up
with Euron to defend against Daenerys
fleet what do you think that she's going
to have to give to Euron in order to get
his help what's going to happen is is my
next game of Thrones video will be on
Sunday because that's when the South by
Southwest Game of Thrones panel is
happening so if they drop new footage
I'll do a video for that it just talked
about the season I'll explain what's
going on
so congratulations to last week's book
giveaway winner Kirk Joseph please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details so there was a new round that
started in this video I'll announce the
winner when I post that South by
Southwest Game of Thrones video on
Sunday but there's a whole bunch of
Logan Easter eggs coming there's some
Deadpool so I'll try to get that out as
fast as possible while you wait for that
you can click here for that other Game
of Thrones teaser and you can click here
for my Deadpool trailer video thank you
so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you guys in the next video
you